- They do a really good job of
you know always telling me
that they're proud of me
and that they love me,
oh my gosh I'm sorry.
(mellow piano music)
- Should I mention
something that I wrote here?
- [Interviewer] Sure please.
- I wrote a little cheat sheet.
- Since our daughter was a baby up to now
we call her our PB&J.
The J stands for joy because
she has brought us joy,
not only to her parents but
also to friends and relatives.
The B stands for beautiful,
for being beautiful person
not only on the outside but
most specially on the inside.
The P stands for proud
because she makes us proud
not only the type of person she is
but because of her positive
attitude in life and character.
- Talented, beautiful, funny, exacting,
multi-ethnic, goofy, loud, cat-loving,
altogether original, and did
I mention funny? (laughs)
If I had been asked to design
a daughter before she was born
I would have fallen short.
She is so much more than I
could ever have imagined.
And, yeah, she's hilarious. (laughs)
- We build up our relationship,
like they all say,
"Mom, you're like not like other mom,
"you're like friend to us."
After he moved to USA,
you know I miss him a lot
but he does not come home very often.
Even I never really just go bother him
to drive over to their,
say lets go out, this and.
I think he need his time to settle.
But recently, the second semester
he sometimes he come home.
He just want to come home.
I'm glad. (laughs)
- When I came to the
airport to pick her up
because she came from Korea.
They had told me that
she was crying a lot and
that not to feel bad that
she wouldn't want me.
The minute I held her in
my arms, she was quiet.
It was magic. (laughs)
I'd never change anything,
and I certainly couldn't have done better.
I think she is a beautiful
gal who has grown up.
She's had her challenges, that's for sure.
But she's really,
knows who she is and
she's just become a wonderful young lady,
I think young adult.
One piece of wisdom that I
would really like to impart.
I really don't like this thing
(laughs)
through dinner the whole time.
(mellow guitar music)
- Surprise!
- Oh no!
- Oh my god! (laughs)
- Oh you're here?
Oh my god. (laughs)
- Oh that's my daughter.
- Is this texting?
Is this what you meant?
Is this?
- Yeah.
- Oh okay, I was like
what does that even mean?
- I got her, I got her.
- Ah!
- Hi!
- That was sweet, thank you.
- Did you hear that?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
It was really sweet.
- You're gonna make me cry.
- No you made me cry.
- Oh 'cause I know, you and dad
you guys traveled such a far
distance to get over here
and I just wanna make
you guys really proud.
I love you so much.
Thank you so much for
everything you do for me.
I think about you everyday.
- Oh thank you honey.
- I was celebrating for the first part
'cause I was like that's right.
I knew she was gonna say that.
And then the last part,
when she said I was like,
when she was grateful for me,
and that I'm a blessing in her life.
It's nice to hear.
- I wouldn't be who I am without you.
- I'm a very proud of you,
and a
he's a very mature child, very mature and,
very responsible kind of
person you can rely on,
you can trust.
- It was really sweet.
It's always nice to hear what
your mom thinks about you.
She always tells me I'm
great but now I know it's,
it's for real.
- It's the truth.
- It's the truth now.
- I'm just really proud
to be your daughter.
You're one of my biggest inspirations,
if not the biggest.
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- Yeah I've very lucky.
(mellow guitar music)